[Musique]
avec Pierre Patrick et Émilie
normalement qui doit nous rejoindre ah
oui d'accord
[Rires]
après avoir porté un jean et un t-shirt
décontracté à l'Assemblée il y a
quelques jours merci il y a soude est
député elle ETI à une nouvelle fois fait
par les d'elle à cause de cette tenue
une tenue pointée du doigt par Alain
jacubo vite ancien président de la Ligue
internationale contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme tenue d'hiver d'une
députée ont redouté Garrido supprimez
votre tweet sans prendre une femme
politique sur la base de sa tenue est
une discrimination des plus classiques
celle provoquée par le machisme ne le
voyez-vous pas c'est ça prend pas une
femme il s'en prend à sa tenue ce qui me
paraît un peu différent
Alain jakubo répond à Raquel Garrido la
façon dont vos amis vous écrivez en
écriture inclusive vous voyez que je
vous fais plaisir ça coûte et se
comporte à l'Assemblée est indigne du
lieu où vous siégiez et des Français que
vous êtes censés représenter ne le
voyez-vous pas tous les problèmes à
l'Assemblée c'est la France insoumise je
suis désolé alors Gilles Verdez je sais
que ce sont tes tétés tes amis mais
excuse-moi Gilles Verdez tes amis moi je
suis d'accord avec Gérald Darmanin il
participe à la bordélisation de la
société et à l'Assemblée je suis désolé
excuse-moi tous les problèmes viennent
de c'est un truc de fou raquette Garrido
vous répond du coup la petite moquerie
sur l'écriture inclusive vous signez
votre méfait qui est député c'est elle
pas vous on pourrait dire que vous lui
devez un peu de respect mais je déteste
les leçons de maintien en revanche je ne
pardonne pas la misogynie que je repère
aisément dire à quelle gare
regarde
la version
pour le méfait je plaide coupable le
respect ça se mérite s'agissant des
leçons de maintien Joker si la misogynie
se mesure à l'autre de la tenue de cette
députée dans l'hémicycle je crains que
vous ayez beaucoup de monde à part
donner et pas que les hommes alors je
vais vous dire à l'âge de 8 je pense
qu'on va tous terminer dans un hôpital
psychiatrique voilà c'est ça la réalité
non monte aussi évidemment
[Musique]
j'ai gagné pour ah c'est pas gagné
encore
[Applaudissements]
et moi de mon côté dans la BC je vais
cuisiner Valérie Pécresse avec cet
ingrédient à l'émission
merci Patrick
on a pris des risques dès le début de
l'émission cette vidéo tournée en
Nouvelle-Zélande pour promouvoir la
Coupe du monde de rugby cette année en
France et déjà culte elle suscite des
commentaires d'internautes moqueurs et
de puristes
en avant non je ne connais pas bien en
rugby mais je crois que c'est que vers
l'arrière là il y a beaucoup de passants
en avant normalement là
c'est pour qui attends
[Musique]
ça va le fixe ça va tout va bien Isola
cette séquence est la dernière en date
d'une stratégie de communication pour la
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
qui veut changer son image en parlant
aux fans de Beyoncé j'adore Beyoncé et
en testant la réalité virtuelle
la sécheresse maintenant qui devient
alarmante on n'avait jamais connu par
les situations univers depuis des
dizaines d'années cela fait désormais 31
jours qu'il n'a pas pu en France et dans
le sud on est à 44 jours plusieurs
départements sont déjà en alerte pour le
manque d'eau
ça va ça va ça va sur ma planète
je te répondrai ça va ça va ça va comme
si comme ça
à certains endroits l'eau c'est presque
totalement retiré laissant les bateaux à
moteur à l'arrêt et les gondoles au
parking depuis plusieurs jours Venise
n'a plus grand chose de la carte postale
vraiment
une odeur d'égout très forte par
endroits qui accompagne des gondoliers
bien à la peine sur l'eau
[Musique]
toucher
deux fois c'est quoi ce truc
qui nous fait peur il nous a pris par
surprise on s'y attendait pas bon
j'avoue ça fait pas très viril mais
heureusement que nos femmes nous ont pas
eu
s tous mes extrémités sont importantes
petite pensée pour Joël notre policier
parce que bah celui à un moment ça va
être compliqué au niveau du taf on va
pas se mentir il y a un moment où quand
il va arrêter des gens les gens vont
dire bah non pas de crédibilité pas si
simple que ça manifestement de changer
une roue
bien le frein à main avant
non je parle à la Dame
des JO le prix des billets donc
astronomique Mathieu de Juvisy nous dit
750 euros et je peux voir la
qualification de lancer de poids féminin
sur un strapontin en dernière rangée au
Stade de France derrière un poteau c'est
cher alors il y a bien eu la mise à
disposition d'un million de billets à 24
euros mais ils sont partis plus vite que
des escort boys du siège arrière de
Pierre Palmade du coup il ne
reste que des places hyper chères RMC
Sport a effectué le test avec l'exemple
d'un amateur de basket telez-vous bien
pour un quart de finale masculin les
seules places restantes sont celles en
catégorie A la plus chère il faut donc
débourser
280 euros pour cette place et jusqu'à
1200 si on s'y rend à 4 en famille ou
avec des amis par exemple citez-moi un
cadeau qui fait plaisir à la
Saint-Valentin Maëva
un acte sexuel
[Applaudissements]
il y a un personnage qui dit pépé
comment tu faisais toi à 20 ans moi tu
te rends compte entre le préservatif
pour le sida le masque pour le corona
j'ai plus qu'un orifice pour respirer et
par là j'ai du mal je peux te dire